con la salida del féretro de isabel
segunda rodeado de flores y de la
bandera escocesa del castillo de
balmoral caras largas y lágrimas de los
seguidores que saben que es la última
vez que verán a la monarca en escocia y
aplausos de despedida una escena
recurrente en el trayecto de 6 horas del
cuerpo de la reina hasta edimburgo la
capital escocesa si era realmente
importante para nosotros estar aquí para
despedir a la reina ella amaba baila te
amaba royal desire y nosotros llamábamos
a ella así que no había duda respecto a
que estaríamos aquí para despedirla para
muchos como elizabeth alexander de 69
años es un momento realmente emotivo
ella nació el mismo día que la reina fue
coronada en junio de
1953 y para elisabeth su partida marca
el fin de una etapa en su propia vida
algo épico con radio mucha gente ha
dicho en la radio y en la televisión que
no pueden explicar las emociones que
sienten por alguien a quien mucha gente
no ha conocido y que es como un miembro
más de la familia
abruma la tristeza de que no vaya a
estar con nosotros simplemente abruma
escocia siempre ha tenido un lugar
especial en el corazón de la reina su
madre era escocesa y desde pequeña viajo
constantemente a la nación de reino
unido algo que explica la estima de los
escoceses por ella los productos al
momento histórico y queremos poder
recordarlo en un futuro luego murió el
féretro de la reina pasará la noche en
el palacio de holyroodhouse de edimburgo
donde sus seguidores escoceses podrán
despedirse de ella hasta que mañana
viaje hasta londres su destino final